like I said I hope some of you actually
go and grab your bill and I have a look
because it won't be that just similar to
this and there's lots of things just
like in this bill in yours and you'll be
like what does that even mean okay so a
few things I mean the bread and butter
are a build like this is something like
this okay you should have a call record
on your phone one day what time how long
and therefore the cost okay that's worth
pointing out when you have a look at
these are these costs here so these
times rather you need to check with your
mobile phone provider how much they
charge you and what unit they charge you
okay now what's pretty standard I want
to looked up this morning from the phone
company but I'm with what's pretty
standard these days you still charge you
by 60-second blocks 60-second blocks up
there are lots of variations on that
some of you 32nd blocks some will do one
second box the reason this is important
is because if for example you see this
is one minute listed is one minute here
okay this might not have actually been
depending on the way that and everyone's
different students a book depending on
the way the your mobile phone plan bill
is structured that might not have been a
one-minute call that might have been
like for example a 31 second call but if
they're charging in 30 second chunks you
went to 30 seconds that was one child
and the second you the second term right
over to third one they charge you the
second one so it might as well have been
a one-minute call does that make sense
so this is important because when you
have a look at all of the different
plans when you look and do this
assignment right they all say oh okay
the amount of calls you have included
are and they'll say it in a variety of
different ways which you will find
confusing but the other phone company
doesn't care about making things clear
to you that's your job to actually you
know make sure why am i spending what am
i spending money on they might say
you've got them you know an hour of
included cause but that our does it mean
an hour it means 61 minute chunks some
incense and if you're like me and you're
getting charged per minute that could be
60 conversations that each last tense
Kunz it's not 60 minutes but i get
charged for 60 minutes yeah it's kind of
like memory you soon as a [ __ ] stuff
like doesn't matter as you go over and
if you like this precisely precisely so
when you have a go back to your
assignment now you know how it says
there look at task a criteria the task
eight criteria it says marginally
awarded for the second the middle dot
point there says use of graphs to
appropriately represent and compare
costs so there are going to be some of
these which the particular name for
these was step craft because it
literally looks like a bunch of steps
okay so this is a really one thing you
need to make it on now I come a lot of
things want to point out on this bill
one of the most important questions is
on this particular bill how do you know
that a phone was purchased with this
plan okay now as I mentioned before I'm
one of those people who did it purchase
their phone with a plan i purchased
separately but in here the thing that
gives it away have a lot is under this
heading of course Hodges that's all of
the usage but overhear their services
and equipment rental okay so it's the
idea that before you've actually
completed this plan you don't actually
own this phone the company owns the
phone you're just borrowing it off them
and paying a lil bit at a time okay so
have a look at these three components
and it is do not only the first one and
you do need to learn how to interpret
all this weird language here the first
one is one business cat plan mr or
whatever that means bonus at twenty
dollar per month what does that mean
they charging you twenty odds you get
ah so this is actually not money that
your pain it's money that they're sort
of crediting to you paying to you and
the way I know is because over here it
says twenty dollars credit right as
opposed to everything else which is just
like this is the amount that you're
having to pay this is a credit they
actually giving that to you have to pay
for that sort of amon as a big plan you
can see this next like in forty-eight
dollars 99 per month that's the cost of
the mobile cap plan right that verb our
cat player it comes with and included
allowance of course so that's where all
this comes from this one hundred
thirty-six dollars and seventy two cents
probably represents a sudden maybe like
an unlimited plan so i expect it exactly
balances with all these actual calls
that you but then underneath those two
items as this guy have a look at it
carefully 124 month mobile repayment
option at thirty dollars for a five
month so this has nothing to do with
calls there's nothing to do good cause
it last 24 months because it takes you
two years at this amount per month to
pay off the phone okay now again refer
to your assignment the last item under
your submission should include is an
exit fit okay so if you're on this plan
for say three months and then you're
like actually this is no good going
somewhere else right but you want to
keep that phone well you've only paid
off like less than a hundred dollars
worth of the phone over the course of
three months and their focus a whole lot
more than that so the exit fee often
represents okay you're still almost
money you want to keep that phone where
you're going to pay for the rest of it
so this is the part that tells you yes
and they're both over to purchase or in
this last but i wanna drag your
attention to is up here okay now this is
all the usage of costs but there's some
weird stuff that's sort of tucked in
there i want you know understand what
they are so SMS now very few people call
these SMS these days but texts are
actually classified often as cause
that's a
we'd right the reason why it's like this
is because the mobile phone network was
built on the phone don't work the phone
network was designed with one purpose in
mind and that's to talk to people right
I want to talk i have a conversation
okay was never designed with text in
mind but some really clever engineers
worked a way to twist the system around
so that your phone could act as if it
was sending a call but really what we're
sending was a budget information that
the other phone represents oh this is
this human text okay but as a result
they've represented as call so this is
54 calls I don't know what the rate is
per text but you divide this by 54 and
that's how much it is you've also have
these things course following the
message make brothers about what would
you suppose said again okay so message
bank that's just that I guess that's
their brand name for voicemail right so
the eight calls represented here are
where I don't it like I feel like it's
very old-fashioned me I didn't use my
smell of my friend but if someone calls
you and it rings out and then you get
the leave a message after the tone you
leave your message that costs you and
then if I have to retrieve that message
it costs me right and you can see
actually costs a fair bit which is one
reason why I don't like but that's why
it's not young so this course don't
overlook this one that calls forwarded
your call good thing yeah that's right
so maybe maybe you have like a business
or maybe you're like I don't want to use
this phone and Big John you have
multiple phones of that kind of thing
maybe you want a call director to use
somewhere else based on where you are at
that time of the day so obviously
because they're a commercial company
they're going to charge you for that
provement right so every time that
happens there's going to be a little
field
last one to enjoy attention to what's
this what's this about cool to the
assume that's the helpline something
okay now census this is this dates the
book a little bit but it's one of the
examples of like you know there are
numbers you can call like one two three
four or like your your provider might
have like a number you can look up to
get like look up a number or give me
directions or whatever okay which all
seem to be redundant but all these costs
all these calls are like they cost a lot
more cuz they provide a service to you
so that's a single call because it does
send in fire that's why you don't do it
very frequently okay so you will see all
these itemized here you need to
understand what they mean all right